[MUSIC PLAYING]
SANDEEP PARIKH: All right.
Well, welcome everyone to
the 1:55 showing of "Ant-Man
and the Wasp."
We should-- (LAUGHING)
so thanks for coming out
to the [INAUDIBLE] here.
So this is "Proactively
Restocking Inventory
Using Machine Learning."
My name is Sandeep Parikh.
I am part of the Google Cloud
Solutions Architecture Team.
And so with that, why
don't we get started?
So what we're going
to cover today--
first I want to walk
through a basic challenge
that we see often in
retail and in inventory--
keeping that stock out.
I want to walk through a
few of the modern approaches
that people tend
to take when trying
to solve inventory challenges.
And then we'll figure out
how we can build a system
to solve for this problem.
What are some of
the components we
can use to address the
inventory scenario?
And we'll map that back to the
components inside of Google
Cloud Platform and what
an architecture might
look like in production.
And I'm hoping to showcase
a little bit of a demo
as well before we
get to the end.
And then finally, I want
to close on questions.
And just so you
know, there are mics
at the ends of both of the
third or fourth aisle here.
If not, if you can't get
out there, just try to shout
and I'll repeat it so that
others can hear it as well.
So what's the
problem we're trying
to solve in this example?
It's produce.
Bananas, in particular.
So specifically what
we're trying to do
is keep bananas in
stock on the floor.
On a grocery store floor--
you can imagine
a produce section
inside of a larger store.
We're trying to
keep that in stock.
Now we can't leave too
many out on the floor,
because obviously
they'll go bad.
But if we wait too
long to restock them,
we'll lose sales, right?
And you also risk that
kind of inventory loss
by leaving it in the back
room for too long as well.
So this is a pretty
high turnover use case
where a lot of product needs to
move off the floor relatively
quickly, but we need
to restock it just
as fast to make sure
we're not missing out
and we don't have to
get rid of anything.
This is a perishable item.
And you can sort of map this
to several different use cases.
But in particular, I think
produce is a good one.
It's a good stand-in for a low
margin, high turnover item.
So how do folks typically solve
inventory challenges today?
And not just produce, but
broadly around inventory
challenges.
So there's typically three main
components in these scenarios--
RFID, cameras, and people.
And if we unpack
each one of those,
we figure out that
it's not a perfect fit
for this kind of
produce style use case.
So with RFID, there are
typically two main approaches.
You have active tracking
or active scanning,
and that's where you've
got a handheld scanner
and you're walking up
and scanning rough areas
of individual items.
The second approach
is passive scanning.
And passive requires you
to install antennas up
on the walls or in
the ceiling, and then
you're basically blanketing
an area with scans of RFID,
and you're waiting for the
responses to come back.
Both of them have
their own challenges,
and ultimately the
costs don't really
line up with high
turnover, low margin items.
You're not going to put an
RFID tag on every banana,
or every head of lettuce,
or every pack of gum that's
in there.
And it also requires a lot
of significant investment
in both cases.
In terms of the
handheld scanners,
it's a little bit
more manageable
because you can actually
outfit several individuals
and they can spend
their time just
roaming around the space
scanning for items.
With passive tracking, you
don't need to send people out,
but there's a high
cost for the antennas,
and the antenna placement,
and there's also a high cost
to actually correlate
each of the readings
and figure out what's accurate.
For passive tracking,
the accuracy
is a little bit more
difficult right out the gate,
so it does require an additional
investment to really get
to the same level of accuracy
that you might get out
of a handheld scanner.
But like I said,
ultimately the problem
is that the costs
don't match up well.
Now what about cameras?
Cameras are plentiful, right?
They're pretty inexpensive,
relatively speaking,
especially compared to something
like RFID out the gate,
and they have pretty
good resolution.
And they actually have a dual
purpose, or a multipurpose.
You can use them
for security footage
as well as watching stock.
But there are some caveats.
So with stock, you're
probably only going
to get an overhead
view of the world.
You're not going to get
down to shelf level,
so it's not a great solution
for every single kind
of stock or inventory use case.
And again, you can
imagine-- like I'm thinking
of a grocery store in my head.
But ultimately, the
problem with cameras
is that they require somebody
actually evaluating the footage
that's coming off of them.
You effectively need
someone or something
monitoring them to
decide what to do.
Which brings us to the
third kind of approach,
and I think one of
the harder challenges
as well, which is people.
In both cases, if you've
got active RFID tracking
or you've got
cameras deployed, you
need people there to actually
administer and operate
this mechanism, and
people are hard to scale.
You've got to hire a
fair amount of people
to get folks turnover, or
get enough coverage in terms
of holding the scanners,
or watching the camera
footage across a number
of different cameras.
They're also hard to train.
You're not going to keep
training more and more people.
But ultimately,
the biggest problem
is that you end up with
a lot of wasted cycles.
You end up having
a lot of people who
might just be standing around.
And as much as I
would love to be
paid to stare at
produce all day long,
it's not terribly exciting.
So one of the things we can do
is we can make smarter cameras.
That's a great way to do this.
Now we have a camera
on the front end,
and we have a pretty
powerful brain behind it.
And that's how we can
solve this problem.
And really what you get down to
is a pretty simple technology
on the front end for capturing
the data that we need
to gather, but we still need a
scalable technology behind it
to analyze that footage.
So we laid out the challenge.
We've covered a little
bit of the approach.
Now we know what our
challenge is, right?
So let's figure out,
what are the pieces we
need to make this
work at a high level?
Let's talk about the
major pillars here.
So there's five major pieces.
The first are cameras.
That's kind of a solved problem.
We've figured out that
those are going to be there.
We also need a scalable
storage mechanism
to store the footage
that we're going
to pull off of those cameras.
Then we need some kind of
a classification mechanism.
Images, video-- something to
put that brain behind the camera
footage.
And then we actually have
to finish this up and say,
how do we notify a store
associate or a team member
on the floor and let them know
that they've got to go restock
the item in question?
And then the final piece in the
middle, there's orchestration.
How do we get this whole
machine humming and running
and operating on
a regular basis?
So the bottom four
components are the ones
that we can do inside
of Google Cloud.
So you can imagine you've got
cameras deployed at the store.
Those need to actually push
those images up to a storage.
The classifier will
pick up those images,
classify them, figure
out what's in them,
and then based on what they
see, they'll send a message out
to the team member.
So all that we can do, and that
orchestration component that
runs it all, all of that
can run inside of GCP today.
So just to quickly recap here.
Cameras are plentiful.
They can scale up from consumer
class to commercial class.
You can find them in all
manner of different resolutions
or black and white or color.
You can get really
cool fish eye ones.
Ones that are mounted on the
ceiling and pan and zoom.
There is an endless
array of cameras.
Trust me.
I looked before the talk, just
to see what was out there.
And you actually have the
option of streaming or sampling
that data.
The thing to remember
here is that if you
imagine a scenario where
you've got hundreds of stores,
thousands of stores streaming
video off of every security
camera, back up to a
cloud infrastructure--
technically speaking,
not terribly
difficult. But from a bandwidth
and cost perspective, again,
you're getting into
that equation of,
do the costs line up with
what I'm trying to solve for?
So you may not necessarily
want to over-invest
in network bandwidth
to stream video
when sampling every minute
with a two-megapixel image
could be just as sufficient.
Once you get into the
cloud side of things,
that's where we need storage.
We need a scalable
object storage platform
to store this data coming in.
So we would have the
camera upload that data.
And you need a little bit of
local device or a control plane
there.
Something that's
on the store side
to capture and
sample the images,
package them up,
and then send them
to the cloud infrastructure.
And that local device
can be anything from--
I've seen people deploy things
like single board computers,
like a Raspberry Pi, all the
way up to rack mount servers.
It really just depends on the
size and scope and the number
of cameras you've got there.
And effectively how often
you're sampling, as well.
All right, what
about a classifier?
It turns out building
an image classifier is
a non-trivial exercise.
You need a lot of data science
expertise and understanding
to train a model, and to
build and train a model,
and then you need a fair
amount of ops expertise
to really deploy
and scale that model
and run it for a production
use case like this.
Again, think of the
model of a lot of cameras
across a large store,
a lot of team members,
and now multiply
that by 100 or 1,000.
That's a lot it's got to
process through and understand,
so it's going to have to be very
scalable and production-ready.
Well, how can we make this
easier on the Google Cloud
side?
That's where the Cloud
Vision API comes in.
The Vision API-- imagine this
as a turnkey pre-trained model.
All you have to do
is give it images,
and what it gives back
to you are everything
we find in the image.
That could be any kind
of classification,
any sort of object
detection, face detection.
It can actually
read words as well.
It does OCR.
It has OCR capabilities.
So anything you would need
to pull out of an image
is possible with Vision API--
anything you need to learn.
And it can do a lot
of complicated things.
Like for example, if you
have two objects in there,
it'll tell you the color.
It'll tell you the
percentage of those colors
as they occur within that image.
So you have a lot
of capability here,
and it's a really easy
API to get started with.
But what if that's
not enough either?
You could imagine
a scenario where--
well, what if you have
a very particular use
case, or a very
particular set up,
and you need a little bit more
than just what the stock Vision
API gives you?
And for that, we actually
have something called AutoML.
AutoML is an effort that started
out of the Google AI team--
the research team
inside of Google.
And their focus was
really on building machine
learning models.
And I didn't expect
you to be able to read
this text, by the way,
but apparently it's
probably somewhat legible.
But their focus was
really on saying, look.
Building machine learning models
requires a lot of manual work.
Right?
How can we make
this process easier?
Well, we know that
when you're trying
to build something inside
of even a narrow use case,
there's still a lot of--
I wouldn't say
boilerplate, but there
are some known permutations
that are certainly possible.
Well, what if we could build
a neural network to generate
a machine learning model?
And that's what AutoML is.
So we've taken AutoML and
we've applied it to Vision.
And now what we can do is you
provide labeled image data
to us.
We can actually build a
machine learning model
and give that back to you.
And so it's a machine
learning model
that's trained on
your image data,
and it's custom to
you specifically.
It's not shared amongst
any other projects
or any other customers.
It's dedicated to
just your use case.
And what's even better is the
same serving infrastructure
that serves the Cloud Vision
API serves your AutoML model.
So that means when you make your
Vision API call, by default,
it'll use the standard
model we've built for you.
But you actually
have an option there
to change it to a custom model.
And you can just highlight the
custom model and the version
you want to use,
and it will actually
use your machine
learning model that we
generated on your behalf.
And what's even
better is if you don't
have labeled images, that's OK.
We can actually help annotate
them for you as well.
So we have a lot
of the capability
that you need to build
something very specific.
Now what I will often tell
people in the real world is,
the stock Vision API might get
you 60%, 70%, 80% of the way,
and there might
be that last 20%.
But let's figure out
what that is first.
So don't invest too
much time if you
don't have images quite yet.
Let's try the
Vision API as it is,
and if that's not a good fit,
then we can move on to AutoML.
So if you look at the
breakdown of usage
in a really simple scenario
here, I've got images
and I want to pass them
through a classifier that's
very capable.
On the bottom I've got
the stock Vision API.
And on the top I've got
the AutoML Vision API.
And again, the only
distinction here
is that AutoML Vision needed
one additional input, which
was a bunch of labeled
images up front.
After that, they look,
feel, and function
in exactly the same way.
All right, so what about
the messaging component?
How do we notify an associate
or a team member on the floor
that they've got to go restock?
Well, that's where
Firebase comes in.
Firebase is our complete
mobile backend as a service.
And I'm not going to go through
all of what Firebase has,
but imagine a system
for authentication,
complete SDKs for
Android and iOS,
and it actually supports
web applications as well.
Gives you real time
database synchronization
behind the scenes.
So it's got a whole
bunch of functionality,
and I haven't even touched
on a good portion of it,
but a whole mess
of functionality
that you can use to build
mobile applications.
And part of those-- one
of those key features
that we need to leverage
in this case, is messaging.
So built-in push
messaging support,
and that's what I'll use here.
And actually, that
push messaging
also supports the web, which
I will show a little bit later
in my demo for you.
All right, so we've gotten
the four main pillars
on the outside, right?
Containers, storage,
the classifier,
the messaging component.
What about orchestration?
How do we actually make
this thing run together?
And it turns out it's a
handful of components.
Not just one.
But the core of it is some kind
of an application platform,
whether that's Cloud Functions,
App Engine, Kubernetes Engine,
or Compute Engine.
You've got four
main options here
that we need to run some
kind of a compute mechanism,
or some sort of set of
applications and services
to actually shuttle this
stuff all the way through.
Once those images
land in storage,
they've got to get
to the classifier.
Once they get to the
classifier, we've
got to parse those
results back out
and decide if we
want to message,
and then keep that
whole machine running.
So I won't go into
too much depth here.
There have been a number
of sessions over yesterday
and probably some more
today and tomorrow,
around the different
Compute Platforms,
but at an incredibly high level.
Cloud Functions
gives you the ability
to run serverless functions,
just like you'd expect.
And those can be either
in Node or Python.
App Engine lets you build more
full-blown apps and services
and let us help you
scale them automatically
based on incoming traffic.
Kubernetes Engine
is a level deeper
than App Engine, where
you have the ability
to basically run
containers and manage them
at scale across a larger
number of machines.
This is where the applications
might get more complicated.
They may have more
features and functionality.
And then finally we
give you really fast VMs
in Compute Engine.
So you have a few
different options here,
and I'll tell you I think
depending on the use case,
one or another might
make the most sense.
I'm happy to talk through with
any one of you about which one
is the right choice.
But for most production
applications, most production
deployments, we often see App
Engine or Kubernetes Engine,
because they have a fair
amount of capability
and a lot of knobs
that you can still
turn to make things work
the way you want them to,
without giving you too much
on the Compute Engine side
and maybe not being too
limiting like you might
run into with Cloud Functions.
All right, so let's
put this all together
and see what it looks like.
So the biggest thing I would
say for a typical production use
case is with AutoML
Vision, a trained
model based on your images
and your image data.
And then either App
Engine or Kubernetes
Engine, and using Firebase.
So those are really
the four [INAUDIBLE]
components that we need to use.
So if we dig into an actual
rough production architecture
that I would typically suggest
you would use in this case,
what we have about 100 feet
up from me on the left there--
capture and upload.
So that's capturing
those images.
Capturing that video
in a store environment.
That little control plane
I talked about earlier,
that local device that's
going to pull those images off
and actually package them up
and send them to the Cloud,
that's that little
upload device there.
And then it lands inside of GCP.
And once it gets
into GCP, you've
got a handful of
boxes and components
here to really drive
this and make it happen.
So the first thing we do
is those images land inside
of Google Cloud Storage.
And Cloud Storage actually has
this really awesome feature
called Bucket Change
Notifications.
And what that means is every
time you upload an object,
or you delete an object, or you
change metadata in an object,
it can actually generate
notifications for you--
generate messages for you.
And those messages can go to a
number of downstream targets.
The two most popular are
either Cloud Pub/Sub,
our messaging infrastructure,
or Cloud Functions.
In this case, I
chose Cloud Pub/Sub,
and I'll come back to the
why I made that choice.
But what I've done
here is every time
a new image is uploaded
into this bucket,
it fires off a bucket
change notification.
That bucket change
notification-- that payload
is actually packaged up
as a Cloud Pub/Sub message
and sent to a topic.
That Cloud Pub/Sub topic has
a push subscription on it,
and that push
subscription actually
can send it right to a target
immediately in real time.
So in this case,
what I've done is
I'm showing it going to
a Kubernetes Engine app.
Just a service that I'm
running in there called,
let's say, Process Image.
That Process Image
service is actually
going to make the call to
the AutoML Vision service.
It's going to pass
the image along.
Actually what it's
going to do is not
pass the actual physical image.
It's going to pass a
Cloud Storage bucket
location of the image.
So I can just say, here's an
image that's in Cloud Storage.
Please analyze it for me.
And it's going to give
me back a JSON response.
I'm going to run through
that JSON response,
look for what I need to--
any kind of restock message
that I want to have in there.
And then if we need
to restock something,
that process image service
will send another message back
out to a different
Pub/Sub topic, which
has a push subscription
to another service
inside of Kubernetes
Engine, and that
will decide to actually
make the connection
to Firebase and say, go
ahead and send a push
message to whichever devices are
appropriate to get the message.
So it's a little bit of
a back and forth here.
But I did this for
a couple of reasons.
You could actually
orchestrate this
with probably a couple
of Cloud Functions
and a little bit smaller scope.
But again, go back to
the original example.
Pretty big store
with lots of cameras.
A lot of stores.
There's going to be a
lot of data generated off
of those images, right?
A lot of images
getting uploaded.
A lot of potential data
getting analyzed there.
So I picked a Pub/Sub for
a particular reason, which
is if you want to have the
ability to fan out and say,
well I want to analyze
a lot of these events,
or I want to persist each
of these incoming events
as maybe a time series
for a later analysis.
Or I want to drive a
bunch of other maybe
downstream workflows based on
images being uploaded, or based
on messages being sent,
before they get sent out.
You have the ability to do
that with Cloud Pub/Sub.
A single topic in
Pub/Sub can actually
have multiple
subscriptions, push or pull.
So that means I could have
different applications that
are going to take
action on the message,
or I could have different
applications like a Dataflow
pipeline that's analyzing the
data coming out of that Pub/Sub
topic.
So it gives you a lot
of power and flexibility
to change components and
swap them in and out,
or add more or less.
So Pub/Sub up is a really,
really powerful tool,
and I don't think it
gets nearly enough love.
I think we should talk about
it a lot more, in fact,
because it's incredibly capable.
It's this really,
really powerful glue,
and you can add
lots of subscribers
onto it with literally
no impact on performance.
No change for the most part.
So this is an example
of a production approach
that we might take.
Well, as part of this I
wanted to show you guys
a little bit of
a demo, so I want
to show you how to put this
together in an example set up.
So the first thing I needed--
if we go back to that
bananas challenge
was I needed some sample
data to test against.
Somebody sent me this photo
they took a long time ago.
This is me in a banana suit.
This is actually not
useful sample data
for the test we're
trying to do here.
So not quite what
we're looking for.
So actually, this is the set of
images I used as a basis here.
So I went into a
Google Micro-Kitchen
and I took the bowl
of bananas out.
I took it back to my desk,
after I got some weird looks
from a few folks.
And I wrote this little
note in there that said,
"Restock the bananas."
And I left it on
the bottom, and you
can see it's poking out a little
bit in the middle image there.
And I took these
images with my phone,
so it's not a completely
accurate representation,
because I've got a pretty
good camera on my phone.
So I actually scaled them
down to two megapixels
and turned them black and
white, and that's actually
a pretty close
representation of what you'd
get out of a common camera.
Color, black and white--
I think that's just
a minor cost piece.
But two megapixels was a good
average at a low price point.
So I started with this,
and what I did was
I tried to build as much
of the production approach
that I could.
So with that, let me
switch to my laptop
here and show you guys.
Perfect.
Does that look
readable to everybody?
Thumbs?
OK.
I think we're OK.
We'll go with it.
All right, so in
this directory here--
and I've got Cloud
Shell up and running.
So this is inside my project.
So what I've got are,
I've got nine images.
The bottom three are the
original-- one, two, and three.
So that was the first,
second, and third.
The third has the note in it.
And then I scaled it
down to two megapixels,
and then I did black and white.
And now I have already
the bucket set up
and the Pub/Sub topic set
up, so if I can show you--
gsutil-- so I'm going to show
you that the bucket itself
is actually empty right now.
So we'll see the bucket's empty.
So the first thing I'm
going to do is copy in one
of the out-of-stock
images, so that's--
Oh.
Thank you.
[CHUCKLING]
Never type in front of a crowd.
So what I'm basically
simulating here
is that local device
taking an image
and pushing it up
to Cloud Storage.
So I'm going to copy
that image in there.
And this is one of
those out-of-stock ones.
So what we should see
in about a second--
all right, can you see that
little notification down there
at the bottom?
It says, "Inventory update.
Time to restock the bananas."
So in that time,
what's happened is
I uploaded the image
to Cloud Storage,
fired off a bucket change
notification to Pub/Sub,
that Pub/Sub topic delivered a
message via push subscription
to an App Engine app in
this case for demo purposes.
That App Engine
app actually looked
at the payload of
that message and said,
OK, a new image
has been uploaded.
I'm going to go ahead and throw
that image to the stock Vision
API.
Vision API came back with
a response and said, yep,
I see text in there that
says "restock bananas."
So I fired off another message
from that App Engine app
to Pub/Sub and said,
go ahead and restock.
Another App Engine
app took over there
and actually made the connection
to Firebase and sent it off.
So all that happened
in about a second.
It takes, I think, about a
second for the first service
and then about a handful
of milliseconds-- or less
than a second for
the second part.
So the first thing
I want to show you
is what that App Engine service
looks like for the first part--
so the process image component.
So that's a little bit legible.
So there's a little bit of
boilerplate up here at the top.
But I want to show that
the purpose here is not
to go through a line-by-line
read of this code,
but really to tell you it's
not terribly complicated.
I spent more time
putting, I think,
comments and some
log statements in.
But really what I'm doing
is just the first thing.
When you set up that push
subscription inside of Pub/Sub,
you actually give
it an endpoint.
You say, send the messages
to this end point.
So your end point
actually doesn't
have to do anything with
the Pub/Sub mechanism.
It doesn't have
to go pull from it
or actually authenticate
to that service.
It just gets that
as post payload,
right inside that
request function.
And so now I get inside
the request data,
and I can actually
turn that payload.
I can decode it
and I can actually
turn it into a set of JSON and
get the message payload back
out of it.
And once I do that, all I'm
checking for to make sure is,
is this message coming
from Google Cloud Storage?
Just in case someone
was able to get access,
just want to have a quick
little debug check in there.
But then I get down into,
what am I actually doing?
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm extracting
the image path--
the full path of that image
that was just uploaded.
And then I'm actually creating a
really quick call to the Vision
API, and it's only
a handful of lines,
and you'll see it
starts right down here.
First thing I do--
I create a little client
to talk to the Vision API.
And then I tell it I want
to annotate an image.
I give it the source location
in Google Cloud Storage,
and then I ask it
to do two things--
give me all the
labels, so detect
all the objects in
the image, and give me
some labels and some
confidence around those.
And then let me know if
there's any text in the image.
So when I get that
payload back, what
I'm able to do way
down here is actually
iterate through all of
the label annotations
and all of the text annotations
that the Vision API gave back
to me, and figure out,
did it find anything
around "restock bananas?"
And so once I find that,
yes, it did indeed,
find that text in
the image, then I
can send a message
to Cloud Pub/Sub
and let the downstream
services that
need to take action-- let them
know that we've got to restock.
And one interesting note here
is if you set up a Cloud Pub/Sub
push subscription
to an application,
you're actually not
going to return 200 OK.
You actually need to
return 204, which is
an interesting little tidbit.
But the purpose there
really is to make sure
that if you return 200
OK, it's actually not
going to acknowledge
the message,
and it will leave
it in the queue.
So you want to make sure that,
yes, you processed the message,
you're going to
take action, and I'm
going to go ahead acknowledge
and make sure that message is
no longer in the Pub/Sub queue.
So that's that
service, and now if we
look at the messaging service,
it's actually even simpler.
So same sort of boilerplate
at the top here.
But a couple of
things to note here
is, the first thing is
I'm going to need access
to the Firebase
backend admin controls,
because I'm going
to use that to send
the actual downstream message.
And then what I'm going to do
in the process message component
really is just--
again, it's a push
subscription, so I just
need to unpack the payload,
unpack that envelope,
and pull out the
data that's in there.
Make sure it says
"restock bananas,"
and then go ahead and send
a message to the Firebase
Messaging component.
And it's actually going to
figure out where to send it to.
And so that set up of
where to send it to--
in this example, what I did is
I built a simple little Firebase
web app called "Proactively
Stocking Inventory,"
and that first little bit at
the top is the instance ID.
That's the specific
ID of this browser,
so that it knows to send
push notifications to you.
And so the way I
got this up there--
what you would probably do
in a production scenario
is store this token
inside of a database
or some other component.
What I did here
was I just actually
put it as part of the Compute
Engine project metadata,
so I was able to
pull that token out
and say, send it to any of
the downstream targets that
are in this metadata key.
So I cheated a little bit
for the purpose of the demo,
but ultimately it was
able to figure out,
I need to send it
to this device,
and that's where the
notification came from.
Now what you're
probably wondering is,
does this really work?
Did I just mock it
up, just so it does?
It always says
"restock bananas."
And the answer is
no, it actually
does work as you'd expect.
So if I take another image
and send it up there--
so bananas1 is actually the
first image with the full bowl.
So I'm going to copy
that into the bucket.
So we'll watch that go through.
All right so, it's going
to copy that image up there
and I could show
you the logs viewer,
but it's not very exciting.
But effectively
what's happening here
is it's making its way
through that architecture
and through that process,
and it's finding that nope,
there's no note.
There's no text that says
"restock bananas" in there,
so I don't need to
send any notifications.
So now if we switch
back to the slides,
I can talk you through a
little bit of that architecture
I chose for the demo purposes.
Perfect.
So for this one,
it actually looks
relatively similar to
the production version.
I made a couple of
little tweaks, primarily
the use of App Engine
instead of Kubernetes Engine,
and I also chose to use the
stock Vision API instead
of a trained custom model.
And mostly because
three images is not
enough to train a complex
custom model there.
But ultimately, I took those
pictures with my phone.
I hand-uploaded them myself
to Google Cloud Storage.
And the notification
that fired back through
came back through my
web browser in Chrome.
But the ends-- so the
beginning and the end of that
are really specific
to the demo here.
But if you go back
to the original,
remember it's camera, local
device to do the upload,
and that's actually a
phone or a handheld device
on the other end from Firebase.
And so really there
would be no tweak
I'd have to do with most
of the architecture,
because everything
on the Cloud side
is actually pretty well set
up like you would normally
want it to work.
It's just a matter of
changing the upload, the input
segment, and which device
you're actually targeting.
And those Firebase
messages actually
have the ability to be targeted
across multiple devices, not
just a single.
So you're not sending
a push notification
to every single team member.
You may have all of your folks
running with a custom-built app
there.
And you may say,
well, I just want
to send it to the people
who are subscribed
to inventory updates.
So now you have the ability to
actually specifically target
those that are ready to run back
to the room and restock bananas
and fill them in.
So where do you go from here?
So streaming-- and I mentioned
this a little up front,
but I think it's
worth revisiting.
I think streaming is an
interesting approach.
Instead of sampling,
taking that raw footage
and just throwing
it up to the Cloud.
And maybe using
instead of Vision API,
using the Video
Intelligence API.
The APIs are actually relatively
similar in that the Video
Intelligence API functions
much like the Vision API
does, except it's looking at
moving images instead of--
looking at it frame-by-frame
within a large set of images
as opposed to a single image.
But it effectively functions the
same way in terms of the label,
object, face detection--
that sort of thing.
But you're back to, is
it worth the investment
to stream that data?
Do you need to have
the network bandwidth?
a more capable device
on prem or in the store to
actually send that data up?
It might not be, right?
Depending on the
size and the scope
of the deployment you're
trying to put together,
it might not be an
appropriate fit.
Well, what about
shelf-based inventory?
How do we see all the way
through the back of a shelf?
We could with
shelf-mounted cameras,
and it's actually
a great partner
of ours, Trax, who's over in
the retail showcase in Moscone
West.
It actually has
shelf-based cameras
exactly for this purpose.
So they've actually
got a really cool demo
of stacks of boxes of donuts.
And every time you
pull a donut out,
it updates the inventory count.
So that actually could work
for certain other use cases
where again, they're
narrowly packed in items.
You can't get overhead
cameras in appropriately.
They've got a good little
shelf-based system,
and it functions in
a lot of similar ways
to what I've shown you today.
What about a custom model?
What if you want to go with
something that we can't
do with Vision API or AutoML?
What if you need something
incredibly more specific?
Well, that's where you can
use something like TensorFlow
to build a very specific
custom object detection model,
and you actually run that on top
of our Cloud ML Engine Service.
And so what the Cloud
ML Engine Service
gives you is the ability to
train in incredible scale,
and do things like
hyperparameter tuning, which
lets you specify which
parameters in your model
do you want to tweak, and how
many permutations do you want
us to run them through?
So we can actually
take your model
and say, well let's
run 500 permutations,
tweaking each of those
individual parameters,
and figure out which mix is
the right mix of parameters
for your model to
be most effective.
And that's actually
baked into the service.
And then when it's
done training,
you can actually promote
that model to production,
and we give you a nice
little prediction endpoint
that we run in scale
for you as needed.
And that prediction
endpoint can be integrated
into any application.
So that's one option.
And then if you need to get that
machine learning work really
close to the edge,
for whatever reason--
maybe you've got a
very custom use case.
Maybe you want to layer in
some very specific detection,
and the latency to Cloud is
just a little bit too high.
That certainly could happen.
Well, running machine
learning models at the edge--
running TensorFlow models
or hosted TensorFlow--
I would say it's not a
non-trivial operation.
It does require a
fair amount of work.
So we have a package
actually called Kubeflow,
which takes all of the
components you need
to run machine learning models
and host them, and actually
even update them there, and
run it on top of any Kubernetes
cluster.
So you could imagine, if
you've got infrastructure
inside the store and you can
deploy Kubernetes on there,
you could actually take
those trained models
and just push them
down to the store
and run them in that
environment inside of Kubeflow.
And it includes Notebook
Infrastructure, TensorBoard,
and a bunch of other
tools so that you
can update those models
in flight if you need to.
And the last point, which is
not on here, because it does
come up--
I'm going to go back
a handful of images,
because I want to show you--
is this approach that I
showed today is actually based
on stock being there,
less, and then gone.
But there's still
some amount of time
it would take for
that notification
to make it through, even if
it's a couple of seconds.
That's still time
for someone to have
to go, get the notification,
look at their phone,
acknowledge it, go back to
the back room, fill up a cart,
and then restock the
actual inventory.
So this might not actually
work for a lot of you, right?
That's where
something like AutoML
can really make the difference,
because you may supply images
like this and say, well,
for that middle one,
we're going to label images
like that as "low stock."
And maybe you want the
notifications being generated
by "low stock," not "no stock."
So that kind of
distinction is really
only possible with
something like AutoML.
Where we need to get a little
bit more fine grain than just
general detection, you want to
add a little bit more context
to what you're seeing, and
that's where some like AutoML
can make a difference.
So that specific kind
of training approach.
So where do you go from here?
What's the first
thing you should do?
I urge all of you, if you have
not had a chance to play within
Vision API, to go to
cloud.google.com/vision
and start uploading images.
There's a nice little box on
there and on that page where
you can just drag and drop.
It's a nice little
HTML5 uploader.
Drag and drop an image
on there, and see
all of the data
that comes back out.
It's incredible.
You can see every single
thing, and if you remember back
to those images of the
banana in the bowl,
when I did those
results and I probably
should have pasted them in
here, what's really cool
is it told me it
had wood in there,
and it had a reasonably
high confidence
that there was wood
in the picture,
as well as the bananas in there.
It actually was able
to read the stickers
and tell me what
was on the sticker.
And it gave me not
only the amount
that it saw of the colors
in both those objects
that it found, and it also
gave me the confidence
that it had that those were
the actual individual objects.
So it gets really,
really specific,
and it's a really powerful tool.
And it's actually
capable of doing
things like specific
brand detection as well.
So if you take a picture
of the Starbucks logo
and you upload it,
it will actually
tell you without even seeing the
words that it's the Starbucks
logo, or the Nike swoosh
on the side of a shoe.
So it's a pretty
incredible capable API,
because it's been trained
across the library of images
that Google has access to.
So that's the thing
I would start with.
Go through that,
upload an image,
look through all the results,
look through what you can find,
and throw crazy
things at it, right?
Because it's a lot
of fun to see what
you might be able
to build-- what
you may able to do with the data
that comes out of those images.
There's so much hidden
in there that I think
we might take for granted.
The second thing I would
have you do coming out
of this session
is check out some
of these other ones that are
coming up today and tomorrow.
So "Injecting AI into
your Applications."
Then gets more specific around
each of the pre-trained machine
learning APIs that we
have as part of GCP.
The Vision session actually
goes into specifically the stock
Vision API as well as the power
that Cloud AutoML gives it,
and where you can
supercharge it.
Then there's also
"Intelligent Image Analytics
Infrastructure," and then
that goes a level deeper
into more and more
of those use cases.
And then the last one is
"Hybrid Machine Learning."
That actually talks
a lot about Kubeflow
and running in
Kubernetes environments,
whether at the edge or
in your own data center.
But it goes into, what does that
machine learning lifecycle look
like?
What if you wanted
to train on the Cloud
and then take that trained
model and run it at the edge?
Or run it in your data center?
So we give you
those capabilities.
So those are some of the
sessions I would strongly
urge you to check out.
And the last thing
I would say is
if you've got questions,
I'm happy to take
some questions
here, because we've
got a little bit of extra time.
There are two mics at the
end, or you can yell it out
and I will try to
repeat it best I can.
And then the second request
I have for you is by all
means take the survey.
Let me know what you
liked, what you didn't
like about this
session, because I'm
happy to do better next time.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]